the lines at america's testing sites
run deep and so does the loss in this
country
here in florida a new record for
virus-related deaths
173 in just one day
it's real the virus is real
monique hicks is deep in grief
two of her children died within days of
each other
twenty-year-old byron was struggling to
breathe
and was rushed to hospital i'm there
and i hear cold blue
so like less than five seconds the
doctor came out and
said he went into cardiac arrest that
his workers were in there doing cpr
and then he came out and said that you
know
his house and heart rate had just
stopped it was you know they couldn't do
anymore
in just a matter of hours he was dead
then days later his sister 22 year old
michaela
complained of headaches and a fever she
passed away
11 days after her brother i never
thought it would happen to me
and that's my thing i never thought it
would happen to me
to see my babies go at such a young age
for one
my daughter they're angels so it was
hard
it's hard what was it like for you as a
mother
watching them go through that struggle
but not being able it was hard because i
couldn't see it
i couldn't be there to talk in their ear
and tell them to fight fight
fight what are the hardest moments
going to sleep at night and it's just at
night
it's hard because the house is so quiet
now
and not with them not being here
they are buried alongside each other the
medical examiner's office
said both siblings had underlying
medical issues
including obesity and asthma
but their deaths also underscore two
disturbing developments
a surge in covert 19 in places that
reopened quickly
and the rising number of young people
who are testing positive
it is stark and it's far from resolved
with
four million cases across america
cordille lynch sky news fort lauderdale
florida